c'est le traditionnel du Nîmes Noël
dinde tourtière patate pilée le tout
préparé par amine le nouveau chef de la
cuisine c'est un bon moment de joie pour
eux et ça nous fait un grand plaisir de
voir les gens sont très heureux de venir
se servir le repas il y aurait
d'ailleurs entre 3000 et 4000 personnes
en situation d'itinérance à Montréal ou
pas c'est un défi c'est sûr que l'on a
les premiers grands froids aussi qui
commence à arriver donc le cieux parle
d'environ 1600 places à Montréal en
hébergement dans les fesses un petit peu
moins que ça
mission holbury offre le soir un service
de navette vers les hébergements mais ce
ne sont pas tous les sans-abris qui
souhaitent en profiter
les règles de vie trop contraignantes
comme l’interdiction d'être en couple ou
de consommer en rebute plusieurs une
commune
distribution de centaines de manteaux
neuf aujourd'hui
et la joie de vivre est contagieuse il
retrouve un peu de chaleur humaine sous
un abri tempo à l'extérieur à
l'intérieur un repas de Noël mijote sur
le feu certains se reposent à l'étage
dans un dortoir de fortune
ça prend du courage mais aussi de
l'argent
dans le temps des fêtes noël ne dure
qu'une journée la pauvreté elle est
parfois sans fin ici Marie-Josée au
Canada Montréal